hello everybody and welcome to drunk
minecraft with me Bob and Wade say hi hi
really inside mark joke what
that's all right let's do together then
nope that's it I weigh them with bucked
up I'm waiting it is you talking get
inside me we're keeping it again good on
me I will do no such thing
Oh No okay all right Alban mark are
recording from the same chair by the way
yeah we're in a rush that house
recording this together Russian
bathhouse yeah I mean Turkish with
Charlie Sheen I don't know I don't know
what people do where are we and why not
permitted to build I don't want to build
I want to [ __ ] these bushes up why I see
some kind of random man it's like still
doing the intro here
Oh episode day ain't hot in my raft
featuring Bob and Wade with another
douchebag yeah these episode markets
wool uh hey how can you build things I
want to build things can't build things
we're not permitted to build things
Tommy anyway anyway for me to Aldi shut
up I got a talk
are you money welcome we some people
were complaining that was drunk enough
last few times so um what I did was
before like half an hour ago I took what
I thought was a double shot but then
again I didn't pour it right so I think
it's like more of a triple shot of of
what I'm thinking
katuns captain morgans hey there's a
creeper where'd the gaffer go well
anyway I had that and then I had a this
tall beer and then I have another one
Bob were you drinking I am drinking what
do I ever drink mark gin no high life I
love started off gin with more gin I
remember that yeah yeah well I ran out
of that gin cuz I drank I just killed
this sheep with its own brothers wool
how do you like this Oh sad I want to I
flowers with wool don't sorry I'm
drinking jingling and probably
make myself some liquor here in a minute
not sure I've got you for this episode
is to get very drunk we've all mark mark
mark has gotten way ahead of us on our
cover here what
over here you're not Bob right behind
you oh you're look at the Sheep you're
buying me a look at the Sheep oh there
look see
yeah okay what's out a dumb but it was
only kind of dumb yeah all right
whatever
anyway was a good information to build
I'll tell my super secret extra special
project that we're gonna do the one
you've been building up for the past
twelve it's so incredible you guys don't
even know I've been do like a friend
penis or something no it's not jack
penis that just be silly but that's a
good idea max eyes too penis yes some
moderately sized everything I'm gonna
say if he builds up the expectations too
much his viewers will be disappointed
with him though they're never just Oh No
right oh yeah so wait up yep no I don't
have permission Dhabi what's going on
I'm testing that out right now
hi guys are Ordet just a sidle screen oh
it's not me why'd you pour me there
that's how I want to go to eat them
they're zombies
keep them there I think I'll just need a
reload that's all Rashed uh well Bob
sucks at minecraft apparently and so bad
I break any weight huh what like the
sound of that
what is it what's happening - way to
kill you ha ha no murder
oh well that's your grand plan Oh
how do pop kill him what yes the
greatest it's it Bob killed Wade from
the grave from the Grumpa not even
having the game booted no joke oh I'm
back
I got a voxel what a [ __ ] am i you're
I'm oh I see you yeah I Hale online
right how'd you get up there I climbed
like 100 like a hunger I know that
sounds excellent what I always say
but anodd also true that's actually a
tall mountain right there it's like a
flat wall 5 8
I think this will be a great what do you
make a spire 9 what all talking about
eight five five shot up and bomb would
you kick weight out of this call oh I
totally would
I just got killed by lightning I have a
right then what I would have to have out
of the game and I'm recording a nude
there are such a [ __ ] I'm on a major
one saving myself I why wait what if I
do know I got so much to do what have
you do what do I do
you're such a dick box just die from
falling ah ass oh the spawn was set Hey
I spun aha go it Oh what the hell what
helix the weight is your fist skill like
is your fisting skill like max level
haha you know it is oh man you got great
experience he waited yeah yeah guy you
got me like oh there we go hey I killed
oh I am so laggy I killed him not you oh
we both killed him yeah wait get some
Internet Jesus where do you live
Ethiopia Wow
I was hoping she out coming did you yeah
how did these African jokes
doesn't have to be an aids joke to be an
African drill a respawn dead hey look
stuff mine my boobs
[ __ ] you I have a sword now [ __ ] you oh
yeah I got this you alright oh no I
can't kill you apples this way already
to this point in the cast didn't know
we're already something serious like for
serial are we starting here and then in
the end we're gonna build a replica of
Taj Mahal oh no
hey sure I'm pretty sure there's gonna
be some kind of psychedelic episodes I
can't see more than like three feet in
any direction oh this is like eeeh [ __ ]
uh how to diet
what what what happens what happened
how'd you kill me who Wade you killed me
when did I kill you I can tie your hands
just a really trippy episode okay yes
zombie anything on my
Jame this is server needs to be like
rebooted or something or I don't know
where's market be it's weird huh mark
disappeared he's gone now
no I still no permission well you're
still no permission I still I do no
permission I don't have I just dug no I
have no no highs you die permission I'm
just like on a 10 second delay oh hi
nope no permission well I'm holding that
dirt so clearly I can dig well maybe I'm
missing a load off or you got kicked
I've left cuz of the lag oh so bed oh
okay well like I'm the king of the
mountain
let's relog and come back in no I'm the
king of the mountain shut up you're not
king of [ __ ] you're such a piece of [ __ ]
hey so much hey the fall is only gonna
kill me after the leg kicks in
ah I have permission bob relog alive bob
bob relog wait i think i have god mode
Bob's me log no I've got my relog Yuri
log I'm God you'll stay God oh well then
I'm eating does nothing why why wanted
to see how bad of a lag you had why it
was very out he just like chilled you
like five minutes ago on my screen
before you actually died on yours I
think five minutes is your [ __ ] Jay
here no not a million close wait you're
a giant look he's one of us just the
wire yeah yeah Wade oh I broke the rule
oh you guys are like praising me before
we record then the good straight back
the hell what no no no it's entertaining
people love to hate that's the
Republican National Convention motto is
it that sounds about wrecking aren't see
people love to hate we must have items I
dig myself out of them no yes yeah it's
you killed us all oh no I glitched into
the mall okay are you ready for this
Hooper just yes
say super no super secret are you I know
it was wait hang on okay repeat after me
does Zoo
Bure secret no [ __ ] you the super super
secret special secret super seekers
we're going on our spongebob binge watch
Bob thing no Joe please
it's going on a spongebob [ __ ] er we
are wait now let's go back I'm a goofy
goober yeah ah no not such a good idea
when you're sober is it weight though
like the most ejected now I've ever
heard
no it's not that's uh okay my other day
that's the sad part
okay alright ready ready for it yes yes
ready
that was dee dee the other day mark hold
on I'm gonna push you off the mountain
okay here we go we're wheeling an apple
we nothing
we always here here are are going to
build a house there's such a piece of
[ __ ] no we've never done it you and I
did it that well actually Bob Holly blew
it up we've never ever that no we've
never built an actual house we've never
had a home I want to live in the home
theater what does that even mean
well we're gonna have home theater
presumably I want to live in that room I
call dibs
well okay then anyway we're gonna
actually build a legitimate house with a
farm and aminals and excuse me then can
we shoot a machinima minecraft cribs but
good not like those other ones that are
on yeah uh I don't think I'm capable of
doing good cuz you know we'll see my pad
come on in those terrible wood you
should kill yourself
definitely could yeah yourself or I
could kill him oh that's me oh boy why
okay guess the mountain [ __ ] kit no get
cereal this is totally serious now we're
super suit
cereal super cereal we're getting wood
haha wood got it
can't see anything or girlfriends not
even there yeah what did you not delayed
keep her here hey blow up the tree you
wanted to that's the best part
no my wood appears to be the only tree
within five miles of us no there's like
thousands of Arctic firs oh there's a
creeper over here Oh creepers over here
hey look [ __ ] man there's like five
Enderman oh it's a big party yay
I should attack them alright these ones
are supposed to look it yeah yeah don't
you know no you look at them and then
they give you treats I don't think I'm
getting treats ah I got it I got it I
got it I got it I got it I got it
wouldn't sword Oh with this a wooden hoe
Oh goddess or mama Shh I love that sound
I wish I made that sound when I moved
really oh go away you wish with a sound
and not the ability to port like ruler T
field sounds the sound only ah you know
it'd be a really fun game what spot a
bunch of Enderman and then try and get
them to reports into a cave under cast
zombie spawn ghasts wait wait now we
have now word now na began the house is
Margo B Oh gasps oh gosh oh it looks so
weird with my texture pack you're such a
dick I'm hiding under the water I'm
facing me I can't even fight there we go
I hit it oh my god it looks so high mati
under the water there's so much lag I
can't even I can't even reflect it back
that's like we're being attacked by
crazy aliens more ghasts bring like ten
ghasts I have the perfect defense for
this I'm going underground haha yes I
already did
Oh closer Oh totally invincible down
here holy [ __ ] Oh God
this is a great idea not how you build a
house no in fact that's just not how you
build it
oh god we have like group a DD like
would build a house we I'm going back
down okay and I'm taking damage there's
a spider please take away the guests Oh
God now there are five guests all around
our spawn that is permanently set as our
spawn oh lordy loo good choice oh
they're gone okay well now I can't make
fun of you for that choice okay
now where he goes Tom be fixed
everything okay so um I lost all my wood
but that's okay they got pills for that
Oh your jokes your unfunny your
conditions unfunny oh it's true
very depressing what I have to go
through oh oh oh
taking on the sentiment by myself all ya
already killed Tim and I I'm the man
leading straight down a good idea yes
okay where are we gonna build a house or
Wes get some wood if I die do I lose all
my stuff for YES on oh that's a terrible
idea then hey Wade uh iiiii labonza no
is doink on me oh we gotta win me spot
alone so yeah what the [ __ ] we were
talking about this before you got odd
Bob with playing Diablo it pre-gaming in
he said something I don't remember what
he got him on me going die
I love Anshe it's good boy Oh who's muy
pantalones esta and oh god I'm about to
lose all my Spanish huge yes
no I'm Omar bet so loose all of your
viewers who have ever heard that song
also labonza historian was it how's it
actually going para bailar la Bamba say
necesito una poca de gracia I don't
think that's how it goes at all I'm
pretty sure it's aa pancha kun I don't
wanna miss me all the air bomba bomba oh
oh
why are you modulating what I'm so much
I don't mind if you guys come down where
I'm at there's a mineshaft no one's
there wood in there guess what we need
yes that's what I am getting is wood
wooden planks everywhere wood
underground wood yes yes because it's a
mineshaft what sir there's blood girl
makes it oh my god there's wood
no there's nothing is there would there
yes we might what disagree it is like a
Chippendales down here there's so much
wood that's the reverse of yeah that
works that's not what happens
I don't we should say Jews it's like a
Hooters down here or a putters or
putters there's so many models just a
lesbian bar to this bar in this small
town I just leave me be help like
someone who works there happens to see
this as like oh the [ __ ] oh god I give
these are the odds of that happening how
does it know first recent recession
brought all around this country just
visit well I don't have the subscriber
base to get that but maybe someday oh my
gosh baroque it's the putters located in
was it Mason Ohio yeah Mason nice that
amazing Mason yeah not yeah not yeah we
sound so convincing
yeah why are we getting struck by
lightning why am i the underground by
myself
why are you getting struck by lightning
I didn't but you know who stone axe
thanks dude
just don't axe I mean iron axe what I'm
down here working for material Isaac
thing waited but dubby dubby don't give
us [ __ ] I think I just took the iron axe
that you made no I didn't make anything
don't zombie don't give us anything
we're tiny I don't have anything don't
look in my hardcore survival moldy Blair
you know when you spawn with armor and
weapons and tools made around hardcore
hardcore man the hardest core I think
hardcore would be not upgrading past
wood and bronze bronze
yeah armor runs leather whatever there
looks like bronze armor I'm going on it
doesn't it looks like runescape phone no
one plays runescape I can't believe your
big ideas the building louse secret it's
something we haven't done you want me to
get my delicious this is super least
like a Saturday new house or just some
like crap house fine no I can guarantee
what its gonna end with that house
blowing up that's depressed TNT is your
main fortress to fight off some ghasts
in an injured dragon oh that a thing
yeah it is actually
oh we should go to the end what the end
what the end of my end no ever ed
serious it's it's called the end isn't
it or maybe I'm wrong I don't it's the
end Earl and it's where all the Enderman
come from ever there's a [ __ ] dragon
yes the ender dragon
yeah ender dragon Bob you don't know
about this I don't know anything about
Minecraft I've actually been there but
now possibly be more clear on what we've
done poured us to the end wait I'm
finding stuff for weeks this can wait
poor no starting our house that we've
got wooden you wanna build a house or go
to the end
no definitely house or drag
wooden tools fine we'll build a forget
house this is stupidest idea ever
it was your idea shut up I disagree
everyone out there whose idea was it was
it was it mine I don't think so
everyone out there knows who Bill Maher
is by now they all know I
it was Mark's idea that guy agrees this
is my channel I run it exactly in what
reality I choose [ __ ] haha Oh God
you know you said you said last time we
were recording you you were gonna bust
out the butters voice and then you never
did what you gonna do a whole episode in
the butters voice at one point yeah well
turns out that's a horrible idea
yes yes is it oh no they all know you
set off my dynamite was pretty good well
that's because like most classic moments
I didn't even get to hear it in butters
voice I got to hear it in my voice and I
thought I was pretty funny it's just
little things you know little little
inputs that really make a difference
what okay where does the Red Lodge
expensing I came talk expressing
discussing re-watching strategy here
what are we uh
what are we talking about what are we
discussing haha guy I'm raid is a great
way to much was the best I've ever heard
that's offensive to ah da I'm word he
says that [ __ ] all the time
does everyone out there would agree with
us Wade that you say special ago -
that's degree that's what you sound like
I'm Wade ha ha
on date models you handsome oh my god
Burke's uh-uh-uh calm down what sorry I
got home down I got a little too out of
it you uh went there yeah I'm sorry I
got into the burgers you should go get
light down here you shouldn't go into
the Burke's I'm gonna start building the
house what are you guys doing I'm
building the foundation for the house
where are you Billy wait I was building
a house
here where it's nice and green I was
building a house over here where you
planted the crafting table next to a
mountain that would be a really great
spot for a house temper our fine house
is a temporary spot you don't know good
design look at this mountain we should
build a house up this mountain oh yeah I
did say that didn't I
yeah and then I said it and it made more
sense when I said it
yeah I'm gonna send you a letter are you
in a mine me what I told you like an
hour ago I was in a mine ah what that
wait hang on man that's not how you
spell mail and my skirm how the [ __ ] do
I send mail I don't understand this at
all I sent you a letter what ah clever
cool down on my letter sending because I
totally sent one before when it failed
are you sending letters for I'm saying I
say you a mail rule ooh not you mail
read I don't want your mail dicks
ah yeah it works it works I got a hand
it's surprisingly I was gonna send you
something similar to that dicks okay it
sticks yeah but hang on where's this
foundation that you also played up all
right it's over here
where check it it's over here what by
the crafting table where you put in Rafi
[ __ ] see now this is like our entrance
down down here to this big landing and
then where I figure we clear out the big
part of this mountain and then like
build it up so there's a room on top of
that big part that overlooks the bay
over there right yeah yeah I can get
beer oh yeah yeah what you yeah yes
Johnny polish oh yeah this is the worst
house I've ever seen
not yet it's gonna get worse yeah you
don't even know no wait what are you
doing being a dick yeah it sounds being
a dick sounds about right
as much weed that's pretty much all my
expect I've been telling you
for the past hour when I was doing about
talking to models a bathhouse actually
yes really
I'm getting texts from her and Emily
yeah oh where this Emily Oh what's
Emily's last name all of our viewers can
Google search her say no just to make
sure I'm not gonna Emily's not the model
Emily is the science teacher oh yeah
there where does she teach science I'm
I'm not giving away someone else's
personal in permit it's her address
where exactly does she live wait she
asked you that question Wade ha ha ha
must answer it's only fair
apparently I'm about to give away both
of your addresses right now oh you don't
know why oh you might know my I would
have a fangirls bashing down my door I
probably would not get too much goin on
don't likes me I'm ok with that I'll be
right back I need another beer uh
entertain them are you we're a wireless
headset where do you go does he wear
wireless I'm not repeated - yeah he and
I have exactly the same same headset and
it's wireless it's fact
all right it's sorry I'm trying to I'm
trying to face pickaxe upgrade time is a
wolf pickaxe good does that sound good
hope I hope you can actually make that I
really do every pretty sweet I'm lost I
would make one just to see what happened
this week if you could make it and it
just fell apart as soon as you hit
something I want you to make a wool
sword and kill mark with it you're lost
just kill yourself you'll come back I'll
lose all my stuff that I've been
gathering this whole time I'll probably
not you know probably and I guess were
supposed to be entertaining right now
I'm lost in a mineshaft trying to gather
materials you could sing - goofy dumbass
song the gute the what goofy oh you mean
goofy goober again we already did that
I already sang la Bamba today what else
do you want from me I don't know what
else can you sing you know any show
tunes
oh god that would be a terrible idea
back now thank god what did I do you
miss tardy weirdly silent ah why is
yours we violate with a single word
while you left
why because I'm yours to feel the pain
of what we feel whatever you are waits a
performance-art like Andy Kaufman they
just don't get it
even though they can't see us moving oh
uh what what it's like that one thing
you did where you like messed up the
vertical lock on the TV screen okay I
kind of made him a chef I'm not cool
enough to get a camera towards the house
Oh anyway Bob first day of school
happened today yeah how's that oh he got
an apple and it resets he got picked on
shut up shut up I haven't at my school
dirty look it's go to school go alright
cuz our doors dark towards our mark
probably took a nap eat you I hate you
general a no-no dude I stopped it I
don't know what I've been missing but
first I was like on campus for 10 hours
today I got in there like at 8 in the
morning and I didn't leave till 6:00
[ __ ]
there are so many beautiful
girls like you don't even know it's kind
of a thing it's bright what happens
every year but I just swear that there
were more than ever before you know it
is rebuilding itself is that supposed to
happen
it's freshmen freshmen that's that's
brighter yeah well no I mean it wasn't
just freshmen but I had one class with
freshmen Wow [ __ ] I just found like the
dopest coal deposit ever is it is like
dope it was 12 coal which is pretty good
considering we're not actually
underground you're just letting a man -
it are you building here anyway I'm just
trying to clear this out right now I'm
building the foundation so really I'm
not actually building anything can I be
a pain in the ass and get poured it up
there so I don't lose all these items
yes Tommy don't do it don't do it Dobby
what you just said yes he likes me
better than you
yeah it's true it's very true so anyway
yeah young girls and boobs is the
summation of my first day at school okay
you know you sound like some creepy old
pedophile it's like the guy on family
good I do yeah
well let me be young guys if I was a
creepy old guy on okay I guess I guess
young girls is better that's less creepy
yeah totally less creepy man I guess
being a gay pedophile worse than just
being a pedophile according to you
pedophilia is equally bad in all
directions this is not a philia I'm in
college what the [ __ ] are you getting at
because you said young girls and boobs
souls were your workers I meant young
girls as in appropriate age girls I'm
not talking about this anymore you just
took it in a wrong direction
like seriously aren't you living a wrong
director having a nice Pleasant
conversation and you just just has not
been Pleasant ever you just destroyed
everything I do destroy every just took
a dump all over everything
oh no can I please get out of this mind
why are you in there because I was
gathering stuff because I thought we had
to get all this stuff ourselves no yeah
yeah we do actually how well you do wait
does we don't I wait does Oh
but my sticks go I took my sticks
Geoff's mistakes I had some stick
did you take my sticks no not out of the
chest I had my own stairs letting a wood
down here how did you know I put sticks
in the chest cuz I saw you access the
chest here he wanted [ __ ]
you took my cobblestone I so did not you
took it I hung out all this cobble tune
my cobblestone do you son of a [ __ ]
you son of a [ __ ] wasn't me I'm stuck
in a mine shaft Oh
kidiot yeah wait is such idiots
man he said iron I've got coal went
idiot he's such man that guy you know
whenever you guys posted the last video
there was plenty of fan support for me
and they should have supported me
because I was telling the truth the
whole time oh he's going there Martha
we're gonna ignore it but he's going
there oh no no no you guys are attacking
my integrity
oh thank god you're attacking my
intelligence cuz that I couldn't argue
it
aren't those like directly linked No
so I evaluations plea done integrally
I'm the smart one of those we need food
or a star II I bet I get out of this
hole why is it rebuilding itself while
I'm in here oh we definitely need food
man we should have got some food zombie
rain chicken upon our heads but not Wade
that's good
if you really hit my head it would still
be above grain roast chicken down from
the heavens zombie can I please find the
group hahaha Joe keep straight up you
know yeah exactly oh I can't climb
straight up build some ladders with Ladd
you were supposed to get with all help
oh you have wooden blocks don't know to
get that much you said there was so much
is but so much the underground forest
aha this isn't right these are supposed
to be roasted
Oh Tommy you were really funny says of
humor that or where it is so what no no
no no what happened was I'll be what did
you all miss that watching the lot
washing the lens way
Tommy's party I would often sporting
wait oh my god oh my god oh my god wait
wait got ported way up out of the bited
fell to him yeah chicken started falling
from the sky bunny eyes out like thirty
iron that was awesome haha I'll give it
back to you I mean we had to cook it
anyway
yeah I was just gonna steal it from you
then hey look I got gold or it doesn't
matter
you guys get materials to rain from the
sky I work from my own and zombie to my
death it gives you everything it seems
appropriate doesn't I've got a raw
chicken in my in the mirror I'll give it
back
oh yeah I could do with it here that was
definitely yours
haha thank you all for your snot rotten
flesh and a leaf you have this guy I'm
[ __ ] chicken Katie don't you think
it's what I crave them down there well
that's a waste there our house in the
mid air house up in the middle of the
street our house is a bit a bit of a
feet Oh
pork you've destroyed every song known
to man today why we only cook there's
only two songs that people know we're no
strangers to love
hahaha soccer Sultan give you up never
gonna let you down
and we're gonna run around hurt you
never gonna make you cry never a goodbye
my high school moves are you
I think ever I had too deep a voice to
be on high school high school high
school music what is it I'm a high
schooler
you're not marks hit on high schoolers
today Oh College no I'm going in to see
oh you sound like Stewie can I do
remember that hey stop - do not that I
will murder your ball ax funds oh I have
iron I I mean I have armor okay I've got
a raw chicken you were killing me with a
raw egg we should have raw chicken
boxing ha ha ha
we all have to get naked wait what wait
what what what what I don't know if my
webcam straight or not I can't even see
it
I'm like trying to focus it in and it's
not working anyway how's this house
coming along oh it's [ __ ] hey you guys
have all my material so you should be
doing something with them I've put all
the wood in the furnaces oh great I'm go
thats what it's being used for I thought
we were building a wooden house yeah
well I mean it doesn't have to be wooden
house we're building a house well
someone's got like a hundred and twenty
cobblestone - Dobby
I need pig spawn eggs what Pig spawn
eggs you know that didn't really explain
what happened to the house that what
happened to everyone where I am on where
it happened where you're at the spawn
Wade awesome
oh yeah cuz I killed I don't know where
the house is from the spawns this way
close out of my voice ah
my arms does that help why'd you see me
molested by an albino spider hold on a
same mark wave at him
I am wait hang on no I know however when
we figured out how to do that yeah I got
it I wanna wait it wait hang on
yeah I'm waving wait just don't get too
close to him
wait look can you see me Wade I'm gonna
go play some other game why is he just
play Jia blow and talk to us awesome so
now I get ported with the hair you are
waiting waiting I'm waving oh I'm waving
ah okay enough killing each other time
to blow a house I didn't even try to
kill you
aren't you proud of me no like five
minutes left and we haven't done [ __ ]
again trying really hard to get this
house off the ground how do we keep
losing all this time it's not about
their alcohol what I didn't hear you I
was drinking ah hi Soph ah I've got to
string and three cooked chickens I am
set
yeah you should go fishing are you mrs.
digger
oh I want to go fishing you get my
cobblestone we should have enough to
build a house the serpent master Oh
eight received a reward for voting oh no
no no no I got too bored to finish that
sentence okay so Bob how's the house
it's uh here let me finish it I fish it
really quick and then we can go on ready
it's not supposed to be out of dirt well
you know I see why this is the house
yeah this is the house when they're
gathering all that cobblestones you guys
could build some piece of crap Hill
you're not allowed inside you don't like
it go die in a fire oh [ __ ] there's
spiders like earth were [ __ ] out here
everything I tried really hard and you
guys are [ __ ] I think it's great Bob
oh you're the best thank you love you
lose you
oh I got creepy really everybody more
like that Herbert guy from Family Guy
Herbert ah that's all it Herbert sounds
like it all
yeah not even close I miss it of the way
you sound reassured so it's a [ __ ] what
you filled in my door-hole who filled it
in the house I think it's the douche
it's such a dick like you know there was
the dude and Wade is the douche the
douche abides by [ __ ] house douches
every I don't get rid of it but I don't
have any my we need more we need um
torches right I've got eight torches
someone had all my coal and all the
edges I have torches Wade no one gives a
[ __ ] about your practicing your I don't
want to cast aspersions but there's a
hole in this house that was a great word
I applaud your use of that word is that
word like casually man I know it's
kidding me
yeah I love that awesome that is great
word you know what else is a good word
what
[ __ ] oh yeah that's a good word say it
again but slower now I'm not gonna steal
all of louis c.k stand-up comedy just
that one part okay anyway we're like
good we got five minutes left
look it's an enclosed house
Hey it's as dumb as the other one we
made it one time we [ __ ]
what watch this [ __ ] Lonnie fill it full
of TNT blow no no no but we have a
crafting wall whole what a whole wall a
crap hole a craft hole a crap hole
No oh yeah this house is kind of a crap
oh that was a hole okay yeah though
don't go too far out of the middle look
what happened to our door
it's our chicken our door our door
disappeared why did our door go away
undo it I doubt the door left oh the
doors over there Oh someone filled in
the door I thought it's obviouly isn't
right in the crab what's in here well he
feels this Judy this is the worst house
no it's great Bobby did you give me one
TNT why did you do it
wait TNT oh boy let his sister player
you like it matters halogen held a
zombie as a girlfriend
well that's fantastic but we can't do
anything about that TNT why do you have
flint and steel
wait I - dammit 40 minutes a word wasted
we could kill the chicken winder ground
again I hope so oh no there's a zombie
behind you it's a zombie dick hey wait
I'm gonna I'm gonna start building with
wood wha
how do I get down wait hang on we got
this I'm gonna start building with wood
and it's gonna finish it out it's gonna
look so good I've got an ink sack you do
don't you
I do oh it's gonna look almost as good
as your mom wait Joe gets a whole
Internet in on your mom jokes wait
oh no I could we have a running joke
with our little group friends it will be
in ways where we constantly you and wait
like yeah I'm in on my own my mom jokes
yeah you are
actually I kind of am we all we all we
ever II one of us in our girlfriends is
banging wage mom even the girls um
everyone of us quite the way that is
exactly how it works
oh okay anyway um we go the gym locked
me out of the house we got two left
zombie fill this house with TNT what no
base
wow I'm in here Bob look my do Bob hi
Bob
oh [ __ ]
yeah no joke wow that's me day alright
sorry this zombie hang on hold them off
I'm gonna craft a sword we get a gas in
here Oh who's first me who pushed me
into the zombie pit not me actually Bob
I want know a singing away from you your
silence tells all I said something you
did not I didn't hear it you said it too
late Oh
anyways oddly this ol that's a good
whole zombie Tod picking out a lot we
got to do our usual conclusion of an
episode well this time we should all be
trapped in a room with it I'm okay
no one else we don't wanna sleep stomach
duty millions millions of dnt no one
escapes oh [ __ ] sorry Bob unless I get
killed by some that's a nice game I
gotta talk to you
ah let's go oh my oh wait do I have the
footage steal photo oh no oh you're not
gonna live long enough to see it
oh no I know I have God Oh
oh my god I wish you really got that
from far away Martha's funny [ __ ] I have
God mode I don't care what happened that
whole mountain just like disintegrated
text everything with TV oh my god I've
got two frames one frame a second it's
it's David tell you kidding Oh zombie
why do you constantly crash your own
server yeah you're the worst mod why do
you let us do this [ __ ] it's a good no
test yeah speaking of which everyone in
the description below there's a link to
zombie server if you want to play with
me I play on the server all the time and
it's not all crazy [ __ ] like this but
it's more since I'm really fun mostly
crazy [ __ ] like this it's mostly crazy
[ __ ] like this you want to play with me
Cleveland look at this from Flo also
there's um a link to my post on
minecraft forums if you want to bump
that that would help oh thank you very
much we're actually out of time so we
will see you in the next episode
everybody bye bye and as always are you